hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game from round eight of the
altie box Norway championship it's a
game between Hikaru Nakamura and Sergei
car cane and it's been a while since we
had a game played by Hikaru Nakamura and
you all know what that means
regarding the photo challenge from the
previous video yes congratulations to
everyone it indeed indeed was me but for
this video we do have quite a difficult
challenge because not only is the person
in the photo very young but also his
eyes are closed in the photo so whoever
you know guess this one truly your your
knowledge is vast so here it is hope
you're ready for it let's let's see how
you do so here it is
I know it's extremely difficult but you
know do your best so that being said
I'll let's return to our game Cara
Nakamura versus sorry Sergei car can we
do have two nice photos here we have one
from the live feed as I didn't find any
photos of the two of them actually
playing of a higher quality so this one
will have to do it's from the from the
middle game and here another very nice
close-up of Hikaru Nakamura by Eleanor
totes so there you have it
hope you enjoy those it's a it's a very
nice game because it's really you all
know kurakin I mean car cane wood black
it's it's pretty much the same as if
it's car cane wood white you're probably
not gonna win that game but in this game
Nakamura really shows to what extent of
preparations he went to to try and
achieve something in this game so let's
see it
Hikaru opens with c4 just a second
we have Knight to f6 so the English
opening is on the border Knight c3 c5
now nice to f3 knight c6 g3 and Bishop
to b4 so the four Knights variation of
the English you've seen this opening
plenty of times and of course Nakamura
and carbine are both very well prepared
in in in such a line Bishop to G - we
have castles castles and E for now
Knight to g5 Bishop captures
big captures and rook to e8 so this is
all still all standard theory of this of
this line in this opening and you know
basically the Nakamura did prepare
something and it's interesting to see
how far circus preparation also goes F
3e captures on f3 Knight captures on f3
and now d5 and now not even worrying
about C captors on d5 Nakamura
immediately gains control the central
with the D for D captures in c4 and now
Bishop to g5 we have h6 Bishop captures
on f6 Queen captures on f6 and this
position was on the board you know in
games of many players many strong
grandmasters once one game that featured
two very strong grandmasters is the one
played in st. Louis in 2015 between 11
early on in Viswanathan Anand and here
Aragon continued with E 4 and pretty
much in every other position players
continued with E 4 and the game between
Anand and Aaron and finished in a draw
but here this is where Nakamura prepares
his novelty he goes Knight to be 2 and
here after some thinking since this is a
new move this move was never played
before
well maybe it was but not it's not in
the database so definitely not in some
strong tournament so nice to d2 and the
Queen to e7 simply in getting the Queen
out of the way as it was attacked by the
rook and also not allowing Knight
captures on c4 now both of the Queen and
rook are attacking the e21 so only now
efore and Knight to a5 by kurakin so you
don't want to guard that pawn on c4
maybe Queen to a3 is an idea going for
that c3 pawn but still you know it's
it's a knight on the rim we have E 5
Bishop to e6 by car cane and now Knight
to e4 and this is the idea behind the
title of the video now you know you know
that something is gonna happen here I
mean black simply has to - few pieces or
regarding the black King there's the
Queen the rock the queen is coming to h5
you know this Knight is definitely gonna
land on f6 at some point Bishop will be
able to support the attack with Bishop
to e4 and you are playing against
Nakamura which you know is something
that Nakamura thrives in rook a to d8 by
kurakin we have Queen to h5 and now
there really is no move that that can
prevent
Knight to f6 so Knight to c6 would have
been perhaps a better choice than the
one kurakin chose as it you know it
brings the knight over and maybe it will
be able to join the defense at some
point but kurakin plays b5 so he does
know what what's coming Knight to f6
check and this is what
Nakamura plays also an interesting idea
was definitely rocked to f6 rocked f6 of
course you don't want to capture the
rook and Knight captures and f6 would
check will be deadly but after king -
Queen to f8 it's not all that easy to
continue this attack you can go rook a
to f1 and still you're keeping the
tension and black can never really
capture this rook but it's it's not all
that easy to figure out where to go from
here
so instead after this b5 idea by kurakin
nakamura goes Knight to f6 check and
what do you do here well of course
capturing the knight will not do you any
good rook captures and f6 is coming with
ideas of rook captures on h6 and rock h8
and that will be followed by checkmate
so after Queen to f8 defending rook
captures on h6 again a rope to h8 a
terrible threat so after Queen to g7 now
Bishop to g4 is coming black doesn't
really have a useful move here whatever
black plays simply rook to h7 is coming
and now you will either lose the Queen
or if you move the Queen then you are
finally getting checkmated with the same
idea so after Knight to f6 check
definitely not capturing the night but
King to h8 which is the strongest move a
king to f8 not all that much rook to f2
and the white will double up on the F
file and you don't want your King on the
F file
so King to h8 and now
d5 there were some other options here
for example rook Knight captures Ani the
most obvious one after Queen captures
located e1 simply continuing to play the
game being up the exchange but Nakamura
prefers a different line because okay
he's up the exchange here but there are
still many pieces on the board and you
know a lot can happen and he is playing
a mandate they called the Minister of
Defense
so after King to h8 d5 forcing a nice
series of exchanges but should capture
some d5 with Bishop captures rook
captures Knight captures on e8 rook
captures on e5 attacking Nakamura's
Queen Queen captures on f7 now forcing a
trade of Queens we have Queen captures
Knight Queen capture screen and rook
captures on e8 and here if you look at
this position kurakin is up two points
although it's a CC pawn but he is down
the exchange so definitely enough to win
a game if you if you play the most
precise moves so let's see how Nakamura
deals with this we have rook to e1 and
here after considering for a while
kirkin decides to capture it we have
rook captures rook captures and now it's
again car cane is up two points but it's
a rook against the knight it there's
very little tonight can do here kirkin
immediately plays c5 and it was in this
position that car keen left the board
and you know he was just walking around
enjoying some other positions by other
players and here nakamura went into a
deep thing and it's a good thing that he
did one move you might consider doing is
rook to e5 with the idea of attacking
the this point but then Carrigan's idea
was Knight to b3 simply defending it and
now that all of the pawns are defended
now a5 is coming then a4 b4 and it could
you know gets very unpleasant for white
and of course if you capture the knight
then after pawn captures how do you stop
a b2 b1 you can go back with the rook
but after rook to e1 simply a5 if you
try to bring the King over a forest
coming if you try and block with the
rook c4 defend
be three now a three is coming and you
know white will not be in time to
prevent to prevent the plants from
marching forward so a very nice idea by
kurakin but after c5 and after a pretty
long thing Nakamura goes King to f2 he
doesn't bite
we have b4 came to e3 now and me
captures on c3 so again winning a pawn
but those are triple pawns on the C file
and then nothing likes a triple pawn
like like a hungry rook
so rook to see one of course Knight to
c6 and now rook captures and c3 getting
ready to gobble up all of all of these
pawns night before
look at verse on c4 Knight captures an
eight - and now rook captures on c5 so
only one point up but again it's a rook
against a knife
Knight back to before and now King te
for we have King to h7 and rook to C for
now attacking the knight and a5 a5 was
very much necessary if you try something
like 92-86 to get the night out of the
way then into d5 and black is lost
immediately if we try to bring the
knight over then comes roof to c7 you
attack the pawn but not only that you
attack the pond it's very hard to decide
what to do with the night if you push a
5 then roof to a7 is coming and now all
of the squares that should be available
to the night are taken and you can
either win the pawn or simply when the
knight doesn't really matter but the
black will be completely lost here so
after rook to see for a 5 we have rooked
the c5 and now a for Brooke to a5 and
now there is no more options for black -
to keep saving the pawn Knight to c6
attacking the rock rook captures now the
material regarding points is equal but
Nakamura is still up the exchange Knight
to d8 we have rook to a six-night to f7
King F 5/9 to h8 we have H 492 f7 and g4
and it was interesting people were
wondering can kurakin maybe save this
position somehow you know maybe create
some sort of a fortress or something but
it was in this position after nakamura
played g4 that Cara can actually
resigned the game why does he resign
well you know he's Russian
you know even as even as a child he
probably learned all of exchange up
endings regarding a rook versus a knight
and you know two points on the Kings
side so he knows that this is completely
winning for white and we're just gonna
show one way why this is winning black
black doesn't really have a useful move
you don't want to move any pawns as you
are trying to create a fortress so
basically what black could say is that
I'm just gonna go Knightly Shane I
understand I teach a knight of seven and
there's nothing you can do about it so
let's see how this works
tonight h8 simply waste a move Knight
goes back and now g5 the threat is of
course g6 winning the night so after you
capture captures now again g6 is a
threat if black prevents it for example
pushes g6 himself then you simply move
the King back in Knight goes to H it
then rocked the b7 check you move the
King and now simply rook to d7 you
simply waste another move and now black
only has two options either he will play
King f8 and he will get checkmated or he
will play the other very unpleasant move
knight of seven but then he loses the
night after king moves king captors and
g6 and once the King comes to g8 it's a
very nice position especially for
beginners you know try to find a force
win here for white so feel free to pause
the video and you know if you really
want to challenge and then find a first
mate in two moves if you want to just
win the game then do that
you know either is fine so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy so basically any move with
the rook you know on the F file will be
checkmate in two except f8 then even if
you found rocky fate you're still
winning after king h7 you know you're
just gonna get a new queen but any move
other than rook to f8 for example look
f2 or f1 you're forcing black to move to
h8 and now rotary fate will be checkmate
so yeah a very nice idea but after g4
kirkin resigned the game and a first
victory in this tournament for Hikaru
Nakamura so very nice we'll be showing
at least one more
from around eight of the altar box
Norway championship and then we're gonna
prepare the standings as well and
hopefully you know the correct standings
this time so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and regarding my cousin
versus Vesely so with you the video a
lot of you are saying that it doesn't
work I have no idea why this is so to
most of the people it does work and I I
reported this to YouTube support and
they can't find anything wrong with it
so it might be due to the fact that
you're watching it through some
application or maybe you are watching it
via iPhone I have no idea
but it you know I I tried it with you
know different means and it works
perfectly and in YouTube support they
also said they can't really find
anything that's wrong with it so until
this is resolved I'm sorry to those of
you who are not able to watch this video
Maria you know such is the way of
YouTube I would like to thank p.m. the
graph for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
once again as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon with
another nice game from the Alta box 2018
Norway championship thank you all and
I'll see you soon